You probably know The Beatles White Album,
and Jay-Z’s Black Album.
But do you remember the Grey Album?
In 2004, the producer Danger Mouse combined
the vocals of The Black Album with samples
from the White album to create a mash-up of
the two…
This isn’t the only time that the world’s
best-selling band has collided with Hip Hop
and r&b.
Back in 1987, KRS-One interpolated the melody
from Hey Jude, on the song Criminal Minded.
In the Wu-Tang song “The Heart Gently Weeps”
they got George Harrison’s son Dhani to
recreate his dad’s guitar riff.
More recently, Frank Ocean thanked the Beatles
for single-handedly getting him out of his
writer’s block.
He even sampled their song “Here, There,
and Everywhere” on his track “White Ferrari.”